MH noch 15 Prozent runter bitte ähm
ehrlicherweise war ich nich immer bei
Allen europawahlen wählen ähm
und Mir war auch früher nich bewusst was für 1
Privileg wählen is.
doch wählen is n Privileg
und es dürfen nich alle Menschen auf diesem Planeten
und mit Privilegien kommt immer Verantwortung
und unsere Verantwortung is es wählen zu gehen
und Menschen zu aktivieren ebenfalls wählen zu gehen.
denn die nicht Wählerinnen werden entscheidend sein
genauso wie die sechzehnjährigen.
also wenn jede Person von uns eine weitere Person
die davor nicht gewählt hätte
zum wählen bringt und das für Demokratie Vielfalt
haben wir viel geschafft.
also nicht wählen keine Option. eine Person aktivieren
Tag die darunter macht irgendwas Social Media whatever
und geht wählen bei der Europawahl.